the first Chinese cancellation uh that
was January 2021 so at this point I was
only maybe five months into Uncle Roger
and like just started to oh I've
people i i people are paying attention
to me just started being known so I
didn't know what I was doing so I
collabed with this guy uh his name is
Mike Chen he runs a YouTube channel
called strictly dumpling and then you go
to his channel it's just food Vlog so I
thought oh yeah it's just a food vlogger
cool so we we reviewed this video
together we're over Zoom we are both
reviewing I think it was Epicurious or
uh some Food Network making a chef
making dumplings at it and doing a
horrific job about that you know so
we're just roasting the food whatever
edited the video posted it uh I I
remember I posted it and then I had to
go back to Malaysia to visit family
because Malaysia just started allowing
foreign residents in land in Malaysia
you have to quarantine for a week inside
a hotel room by yourself it is very
normal procedure at a time again
negative test quarantine the hotel room
for a week and then I remember just
unpacking the hotel room sleeping waking
up and then I got a message from my the
people who manage my Chinese social
media I just started uh way Boy and
Billy Billy at the time way boy is
Chinese uh Chinese Twitter like platform
and Billy Billy is Chinese YouTube
so I just started those platforms paid a
bit of money up front for them to start
it and then I I got a message from them
saying my Chinese social media agent
saying hey Nigel your video you're
getting your accounts getting reported
because apparently that Mike Chen guys
on Strictly dumpling
is one uh very very
ntccp publicly on his social media and
two is also part of this organization
called falun gong are you familiar yeah
yeah okay you are by I guess so tell our
audience a little bit more tell our
words a little bit more about fun yeah
it's
I have to be careful my words you're
doing against sued you know so yeah be
careful because we could get serious as
well so extra careful I hope you have
liability insurance yeah uh so it's an
organization
um a lot of people think it's a cult but
if you ask someone from falun gong
they'll just say uh they are an
organization a spiritual organization
that practices the the three Universal
truths of honesty forbearance and
compassion you know whatever that means
right but a lot of people online think
it's a cult right and it's a cult that's
very very let's think of it as Chinese
Scientology but apparently some
happened uh when they were in China the
the founder of that of alun gong fled
China and nobody really knows what
happens just we I just know some
has gone down and all this stuff is
impossible to research online especially
on Western internet
and uh like it's just impossible to find
you you'll find resources from falun
Kong affiliate organizations say oh we
are just uh organized we just do tai chi
in the park every day you know why are
you persecuting us and then you see on
the China side I said no they did a lot
of crazy back then so do your own
research are not gonna say anything that
would incriminate me so basically
if you're a seat in China if you're seen
working with someone from this
organization that's an automatic band
you'll be like Persona and on grata you
can't even enter the country so that's
why my accounts were getting reported
because people think
in Chinese social media you get a lot of
these over here call them social justice
Warriors that is their flavor they're
very jingoistic nationalist types people
say oh can you have you seen Uncle Roger
work with this guy and then they would
just they have these National list Pages
they would have their fans report you
kind of doxing you you know so that's
how my accounts got uh um what's about
to get suspended and I said oh what
do you do I I have no clue I was I was
new to this whole social media thing
right so I asked my Chinese social media
agents who were uh a lot of them were
all of them were Chinese people based in
China so they said oh yeah well when
something like this happens usually we
just issue a statement and then take
down the video that should go away and
then and then I was like oh okay I had
no clue right so I said just just handle
it just handle it so they wrote me a
statement I read it I was like oh yeah
it feels like you know copy and paste
boilerplate a statement yeah that's just
like that's just post it but then I
posted a statement
um
then then someone on Twitter now it's
West the Western World say oh have you
seen Uncle Roger apologizing and cow
towering to the CCP I was like oh I
read the statement back I was like oh
yeah okay it does sound like in
hindsight if if I if I were to do things
differently I would probably like be
more involved in in that process and be
like no let's not post this because it
does read like I am apologizing I
basically stepped on the landmine you
know the the fact that to me that video
was not political right but the fact
that and I didn't even post it on
Chinese socials but somebody from
Chinese social screenshotted me on
YouTube working with this Mike Chen guy
and then posted on weibo and Billy Billy
and said look at this Uncle just working
with a known cultist and then uh that
made it political so at that point it
was lose lose either way if I kept the
video up I would have nuked my Chinese
socials if I took the video down the
Western would have hated me you know so
who did you pick well at that time I was
like oh I just thought of the Chinese I
didn't know it was going to be such a
big that was my naivete and I owned that
mistake now definitely so yeah I picked
taking a video down because I was like
oh my Chinese fans seemed cool they like
they're like me let's just keep it going
yeah uh and that became very political
and then when I took the video down and
the Western world started hating on me
uh Mike Mike Chen he was I this pissed
me off a little bit you know because
sure I did have to unfollow him on my
Chinese social media uh agent's orders
and I think he he he should know what is
going on but then he just went on all
this because he's part of the falun go
and this is a known fact he promoted on
his channel that he's part of this
most people they will know Shen Yun that
that show the Chinese uh tube adverts
and seal of two adverts on the show so
that that's just Affiliated so right
right when the Western world started
hating me my chance started doing his
whole rounds of podcasts because the
falunco owned a lot of YouTube channels
you know the The Epic Times is that's
how I know about it because we've I've
done a couple of shows on their platform
and we know someone there who's actually
not Chinese yeah yeah I think it's part
part of it yeah it's not is that is the
Western Falcon's Western arm and then
they also have the new Tang Dynasty
which is a YouTube channel uh a few
other channel I think China uncensored
on YouTube is also part of the
organization and a lot of people say
there's not me a lot of people are
saying that my Chen is pretty high up in
the Falcon organization so he has
friends in all these channels and he was
doing just a podcast around like you
know doing the Rogan circuit yeah was he
slagging you off was he was that what
happened yeah yeah this is through under
the bus a little bit Yeah it threw me
under the bus so that was why I was a
little bit oh come on dude I'm new to
this world I'm operating off the back
foot here I don't know I don't even know
why I got canceled I'm researching
everything and they threw me under the
bus so now people say uh we will get to
the second cancellation but people ask
now that China hates you are you gonna
put on that old dumping video out I was
like nah because it just doesn't feel
great being a pawn in this in this war
between the the China China's the ccp's
propaganda and then the salunkongs
propaganda so yeah I just left a shitty
taste in my mouth
thank you